um new culture secretary here in the
studio Michelle Donald hi good to see
you good morning 2.3 billion is what Liz
trust is promising again where's that
money coming from with the second
biggest military down and we are
committed to doing that again next year
we'll outline exactly the details of
where that funding is from but we
believe as government is fundamentally
important that we're standing up for
democracy that we're continuing to
protect Ukraine in their fight back and
that we're standing up uh for the rest
of the world who needs to end their
Global dependence uh on Russia which is
one of the factors behind the increasing
price in fuel so this is actually going
to help the cost of living of people not
just in the UK but across the globe as
well and we hope that other countries
will uh we'll see what we're doing and
follow our example but where's the money
coming from as I said a moment ago okay
we will outline exactly where that money
is coming from but I'm sure that you
agree with me that this is
the Chancellor's physical on Friday the
physical event the physical event is on
on Friday I'm not going to preempt
exactly what he's going to say in that
event but we'll be outlining their more
support in terms of cost of living
looking at taxation like we promised
during the campaign to secure Liz trust
as prime minister and all the details
will be be coming out on Friday the
reason our bills are so high is because
of the war in Ukraine how high uh do
those bills have to go before we have to
reevaluate our support
no no this isn't about our support this
year this is about saying that we are
going to continue our support next in
terms of the Ukraine if you're talking
about
um support for for people in a country
we've already given considerable support
so we put the money into the household
support fund we also gave the money on
council tax but what we've announced as
a government that's only just been
imposed for two weeks with this new
prime minister is an energy price
guarantee where we are assuring the
British public that they will get at
least a thousand pounds of their energy
bills had we not acted and that's on top
of the other measures we've taken in the
coming months people will get 400 pounds
of their energy bills irregardless of
their income the most vulnerable in
society will be getting at least 1 200
pounds so you've got to look at the
package in the round there's a great
deal of support that we've been putting
in place we've always been honest that
this winter is going to be hard and one
of our overarching priorities is to
support people through it whilst also
growing the economy and preventing this
from ever happening again yeah sorry I
didn't explain myself very well my
question is the reason that bills are
going up as high as they are is because
of the situation in Ukraine it's a big
driving Factor yes so how high do our
bills have to go before we re-evaluate
our support in Ukraine well I don't
think that is the case we're not
re-evaluating our support in the Ukraine
what we're saying is we're doubling down
on our support in the UK so how high do
bills have to go it doesn't matter how
high they go what no so we've already
allocated 2.3 billion to support uh
Ukraine in terms of the military effort
where the third uh biggest supporter in
terms of humanitarian effort what we're
saying in this announcement is our
support for next year we're committing
again to support the Ukraine by the same
tune and we're encouraging other
countries around the globe and that's
what the Prime Minister will be doing at
the UN General Assembly to ensure that
we're all working together to support
the Ukraine to help bring those bills
down which also up because of covid as
well as you know yeah what's the Prime
Minister going to be talking to Joe
Biden about given that a trade deal is
not on the table
I can't go into details of exactly what
the Prime Minister will be talking about
in a bilateral meeting but what I can
say is that that will be happening this
week it's a uh it's it's in the diary
you UK and the US have enjoyed a very
special relationship over the years we
want to cement that solidify that and
make sure that that relationship is is
completely fostered between both of
those leaders but looking at what Liz
trusts our prime minister has said it
doesn't look as though there's a trade
deal on the table well look
um the the Prime Minister and the
president will be meeting this week
they'll be talking about a variety of
different issues including potential
trade deals so let's see what comes out
of that meeting not according to listro
she said not well yes so I'm saying
she'll be talking about a range of
different things the purpose of this
meeting is not to secure a trade deal
this is the first bilateral meeting
between the newly elected prime minister
and the president of the United States
talk to me about
um the Queen's funeral how much did it
cost the taxpayer uh we haven't got that
total figure but I think you know the
taxpayer would argue that it was is
money well spent in my own constituency
I saw so many people coming out to
celebrate for the Jubilee across the
community and in dcms the department
that I lead we've been leading on on the
efforts around the queue and and that
was remarkable and not just the amount
of people how many people queue do we
know um so over 250 000 went through uh
went through Parliament and we're just
crunching the final numbers that's an
approximate figure at the moment okay
but we'll get back to you with the exact
one and it wasn't just those people it
was also the community that rallied
around that you know we had St John's
ambulance sporting we had this Merit in
supporting we had the Red Cross
supporting we have members of the public
coming up with you know items of cake
and food and it was a great sense of the
community coming together I always think
of um of our late monikers the glue that
brought Society together and communities
together and in her in her final sort of
act that's exactly what she did and it
was remarkable to see that on the ground
having spoken to members in the queue
they've come from afar all over uh the
four corners of the nation and they felt
determined and Beyond yeah and Beyond um
seat so more than 250 000 when were we
accidentally yeah yeah
um when will we know the cost of the
funeral given that we don't know yet uh
look I'm I'm not uh sure of the exact
costumes but as I said
um I think the British public you know
would argue that that was money well
spent you saw so many thousands out
there and I don't think anybody could
suggest that our late Monarch didn't
deserve that send-off given the uh the
duty and the the selfless service that
she committed to over 70 years I think
it would be downright Preposterous to
suggest we shouldn't have celebrated
exactly how much it cost yeah so I've
said I don't have that those bigger
stuff but we will have it in the
fullness of time so that wouldn't be uh
my decision to take care okay
um talk to me about when you were at um
education I mean you weren't there very
long were you well I was I was there for
over three years yeah as the Secretary
of State how long were you there yeah so
well as you know the answer already okay
it was 36 hours but I was serving in the
cabinet for 10 months and with all that
minister in two different roles so I was
there for over three years okay 17 000
pounds is what you've got apparently as
a payoff as you said you said that one
as well yeah exactly that okay so you
you said that you were going to give it
to a charity no I didn't I said the
eighth I wasn't able to reject the money
I would give it to a charity but I
rejected it oh okay okay I didn't know
that question okay I'm surprised you
didn't give it to a charity but there
you go well it was taxpayers money so I
think it would be wrong for me to take
tax pays money then decide you know
which charity I wanted to give it to so
I was very clear that if I was able to
reject it I would reject it and I did
okay talk to me about the online harm
Bill where are we going with that
um so it's a vital piece of legislation
it was in our Manifesto as we know the
world has changed remarkably and it's it
is important that we prioritize
protecting children having spoken to a
number of parents and and organizations
in this sector you know it is important
that we fill in the gaps in our
legislation and protect children which
is what this bill does so we're going to
get it back to Parliament as soon as
possible finish it off it's been through
most of that for a long time I remember
interviewing the chief exec of ofcom
more than a year ago and it was supposed
to become law last year still waiting
well it's gone through most of the
stages as we've just elected a new prime
minister we've had a period of national
morning we will be bringing it back to
the house as soon as we possibly can it
does require a little bit of work not in
relation to uh protecting Children
online absolutely not we're not changing
any of that but we want to make sure
that we've got the balance right in
terms of free speech in relation to
adults so when will it become law as I
just said as soon as possible we bring
it back to the commons and we do need to
edit that bill so we're just in the
process of getting that done and then
we'll be bringing it back of course we
couldn't have done this automatically
becoming 10 days because we had a period
of now yeah we've had plenty of time
before that yes but I've only been in
post two weeks okay and what I'm saying
to you today
what I'm saying to you as I sit here
today is that I'm giving you my cast
iron guarantee that I'm committed to
this it's my number one priority I'm
going to make sure that the bill is
slightly tweaked bring it back to
Parliament as soon as possible because I
completely understand why this is a
vital piece of legislation to protect
Children online do uh big tech companies
do enough to protect our kids
I think that the problem is is that it
can be inconsistent and they are always
held to account on this so the answer is
no which is why we're bringing forward
legislation to ensure that they do uh
when you say a Helter account which ones
in particular hold them to account well
that's why we're bringing forward
this bill is primarily focused uh well
it is focused uh providers that um
generate online content so a lot of that
is is social media providers and we've
got the inquest starting today in the
absolutely tragic case uh of Molly
Russell and and we all know that she is
just let's just remind our viewers she's
14 and she she killed herself yeah um as
a result of online harm back in 2017 I
mean are we looking at
um people like Facebook people like
Twitter they need to Instagram they need
of course Facebook they need to be doing
more but they do need to be doing more
which is why we're going to legislate to
ensure that they do so that we have
um the not only the legal powers to do
so but also we can then whack them with
massive massive fines which then is a
big deterrent and ensures that they act
in a responsible way from the off will
you abolish the BBC license fee uh so
I've only been in the post two weeks but
what I can say is over the last few days
the BBC did a tremendous job as did Skye
in covering a very poignant moment in
British history as we celebrated the
life of our late Monarch but it's it is
no secret that I have been a long-term
skeptic of the license fee and that we
need to make sure that the BBC is
sustainable in the long term so I'm
looking at this in the round I'm
somebody that listens I'm somebody that
decides policy based on evidence and
that's what I will be doing over the
coming weeks yeah you pointed out that
although you were only at in post two
weeks you've been in government for many
years I'm sure that the BBC license fee
has come up on on occasion
um do you think it's time for it to be
scrapped I think we need to make sure
that the BBC is sustainable in the long
term
I've already said what does that
actually mean well it means that in an
age when you have Netflix you have
Amazon Prime you have all of these other
subscription-based uh channels then it
does their own to question where over
the current model that the BBC uses is
actually sustainable in the long term
and is providing that choice element to
the general public but as I said you
know I'm somebody that listens I make
decisions based on evidence that's what
I will be doing over the coming weeks
I'm not going to make policy on the hoof
I don't think that's the right approach
when we're looking at these big policy
decisions okay good to talk to you
thanks for taking the time to join us
thank you very much indeed thank